magician jay owen house wants to bring
his tiger show to an empty lot at sahara
and paradise but the winchester town
advisory board voted no joe mohler is
live near desert inn in pecos with what
will happen next
[Music]
tonight the winchester town advisory
board heard a lot of opposition to the
show involving tigers many saying a
parking lot is not a place for tigers
now there still will be one more meeting
where this will be considered this
project is a far cry from the sanctuary
the idea of bringing tigers back near
the las vegas strip has many upset you
have to have airline cable tethered
around the animal's neck
to ensure safety why even go there
magician jay owen house has an idea to
bring his magic show to las vegas with
the use of tigers he has a plan to pop
up tents and build what they are calling
a temporary sanctuary at sahara and
paradise to block away from the strip we
don't want our tigers to have to have
the stress of being transported from one
location to another every day christina
owenhouse says it isn't only about the
show but also awareness the tigers are
in the show for about eight minutes of a
total so not a lot but enough for the
audience can see them and see us
interact with them and i think that
really softens their hearts to tigers
and inspires them to protect them after
hearing the plan and public comment
tuesday night
the winchester town advisory board voted
to recommend the county deny the plan
for years now big cat acts have been
failing on the strip a majority of
people attending were happy to hear
about what happened kind of pop up a
circus tent and have a magician
you know
bring a couple tigers out for a couple
minutes it's just that's a thing of the
past people aren't interested anymore
the winchester town advisory board voted
against this idea now their
recommendation will be sent to the
county next month where commissioners
will vote on a final decision reporting
at d-i and mcleod joe mohler live local
now